the US gymnastics championship
tournament begins today but the sport is
still reeling from the scandal over
abuse by former US national team dr.
Larry Nasser Nasser is serving up to 235
years in prison after he was found
guilty of sexually abusing athletes in
his care for decades at a sentencing
hearings earlier this year more than 250
athletes read victim impact statements
against him were very powerful now first
on CBS this morning two more former
Olympians are coming forward with their
stories Kyla Ross competed in the 2012
Olympics as a member of the famous
fierce five we remember you Kyla when a
team gold medal Madison also known as
Maddie koushin won a silver medal on the
uneven bars as a member of the 2016
Olympic team they also won a team gold
medal both are members of the current
NCAA champion UCLA gymnastics team
that's led by coach
valorie Kondos feel a 36 year veteran so
we reached out to us a gymnastic was
told us this USA gymnastics support is
unwavering for Kyla Madison and all
athletes who courageously came forward
to share their experiences their
powerful voices and stories will
continue to be a basis for our future
decisions Kyla Ross and Maddie Cowan and
valorie Kondos feel join us at the table
good morning to all of you
good morning I want to start with that
statement guys from US gymnastics
because when you hear that you think
what do you believe what they're saying
their support is unwavering have you
heard from them personally we both have
not heard anything and it's been
saddening to know that a lot of a lot of
gymnast has have gone through this event
and they have not reached out and seeing
how we're doing as people not as just
athletes but as individuals who grew up
in the sport just to know that the set
for you Maddie you've never heard
anything yet when they say our support
is unwavering what do you make of that
statement yeah still to this day I
haven't heard anything
I even even asked after Larry Nassar
resigned and was asked to leave I
haven't heard anything from them I went
to compete out world championships in
fall of 2015 and the Olympic Games in
2016 and still
this day I haven't heard any anything
what would you like to hear from them
for me personally just an apology and
just to know that it's more than just
support it's help and we all experienced
such this awful event and to know that
we competed all those years for our
country and that we were disrespected in
this way by this doctor and you know
that had happened to so many people is
very disheartening
Valarie what do you make of this this
reluctance here that we've just been
exploring and the original behavior by
USA Gymnastics it said excuse me it's
unfathomable we just can't really put
your wrap your head around it and you
know having been at UCLA for so many
years and hearing the same stories from
these athletes telling the saint using
the same words that they felt it was a
culture of fear that they were training
under they were it was a culture of
silence a culture of winning a culture
of winning and what became so clear
through all of this it's just is that
any time you put winning and medals
above people you're gonna open up your
organization to a corrosiveness that
will just spread like a disease and we
keep hearing girls that he got away with
it for so long because of his
personality what does that mean Maddie
and Kyla what was his personality that
he was able to get away with this it was
almost like a family a family member and
he would on international trips he would
bring us food or he would just kind of
be the person that would always ask how
are you doing because the culture that
was at the Curley ranch was a culture of
fear a culture of silence and that's
what led him to be able to abuse us and
he's been caring exactly we reached out
to the Corollas who have not commented
you so we should we should mention that
but this this culture Kyllo i mean what
is it like when you're in the middle of
it is it basically you have to just
focus on winning and that's it yeah
being on national team for all those
years we were really silenced we we
didn't really have a voice and say as
athletes and I think that being able to
compete at UCLA under the care of miss
Val and all our coaches we realized that
as an athlete we should have a voice and
this is our sport and we should enjoy it
and not too
be there to to in metal did you all not
talk to each other did you all think
that this was abuse or did you just
think this was a weird treatment I'm
amazed that it happened to so many girls
at the same time was there no
conversation amongst us there was
conversation and I think it was such a
normalized thing that between us we
didn't think any different of it what
did you think was happening Matti what
did you think he was doing we were told
that I was a medical procedure too a lot
of us had back injuries or hamstring
injuries and that was our only option
because he was our team doctor and if we
were to speak up that was our only
Avenue to accomplish our Olympic dreams
and so if we were to speak up there you
you probably wouldn't have been in that
consideration for making that team in
faleri you knew Larry Nasser I mean so
many people are questioning what were
the adults thinking how did they not see
the warning signs can you address that
from an adult's perspective sort of
watching what it was taking place I
believe it's because we protected Marta
Karolyi
the USA Gymnastics was more concerned in
protecting Marta Karolyi than checking
in on our children because they were
children they were 12 13 years old at
the time and Larry was as they said a
very kind he was a gentle man you
thought he was too I did I put on his
facebook happy birthday to a gentleman
and the karoli said they didn't know
they had no idea until 28 that I believe
in vaccine games
I believe that well you believe that
that was a nice gentleman but the that
wasn't the problem problem was that they
did not have anybody to go to and that
there was that they were so isolated at
the ranch and then we protected Marta so
much you didn't question Marta
nobody questioned Marta mm-hmm why
because she won mm-hmm and winning was
very important and when I asked why do
we allow why I was just talking about
the verbal abuse in the the mental abuse
why do we love that they said they
looked at me like I was crazy they said
because she wins now I'm curious as to
how this has affected you guys long-term
because it's very tragic just reading
the details are just very ugly and very
uncomfortable how's it affected you Kyle
long-term at first hearing all the news
about Larry I really wasn't denial of it
ever happening to me I really at that
point in my life when I was 13 when it
first happened to me
I believed that it was a legitimate form
of treatment but as the years have gone
on and hearing all the impact statement
of all the girls that have come forward
already I realized that it was something
that a terrible event that had to happen
to us but and you dealt with it home
just being able to be supported by my
friends my family and a lot of the other
survivors I've been fortunate enough to
have good support definitely been a hard
road but to know that there's people
that are caring about us including their
coaches their personal coaches are
amazing and we're really grateful that
all of you're here and thank you kindly
yeah thank you
Hilary thank you and that they're stars
on the UCLA Jim Nelson yeah
[Laughter]